hey guys I'm Callie I'm here with John
Luke and we got to play Wolfenstein to
the new Colossus the sequel to
Wolfenstein the new order and we're
really excited about its we played two
sections in the demo one was from e3 so
we'll start with that one it was a
wheelchair like opening wheelchair
sequence and a u-boat I really liked it
what did you think yeah it's like the
beginning of the game BJ is crippled
then he has to like move in this
wheelchair and if you're not familiar
BJ's the protagonists from York right
yeah it's a direct continuation of the
previous game and it's really fun too
well at first it feels like it wouldn't
be fun because you're moving this
wheelchair and it intentionally kind of
restricts parts of your movement it
feels a little bit janky in the way like
it moves and you have to like build up
speed to get over like the little like
like well there's like that uh you know
yeah there's a kind of bump over the
door right exactly you think about a
submarine like that's how the doors are
structured so it's a little awkward it's
weird
and you're you're like shooting with one
hand and wheeling with the other they're
gonna try and capture the experience of
one-handed shooting Nazis in a
wheelchair yeah as what does this one
does so yeah but the cool thing about
that is it feels really awkward to play
it's but in janky but even foot way it's
fun it doesn't feel like broken right it
doesn't feel like oh this isn't how this
is supposed to move it intentionally
breaks down the kind of movement you
would expect from a game like this which
I really liked and it's such a cool
introduction to what you're going to be
doing you're like setting traps and you
have to kind of sneak around but in a
way that's not very sneaky it's that's
infection it's so cool I've replayed it
several times now just because I was
just really into kind of mastering going
around the the u-boat so it's really
interesting
the second section we played was a
little
it was in area 51 yeah we're getting
about a minute which is very Wolfenstein
they're going all the way absolutely if
you're gonna Wolfenstein it's always
been like super pulpy yeah and if it's
like okay if you're gonna really lean
into the Americans like 60 setting with
Nazis like you gotta put it there you
got to put an area 51 the Nazis are
taking over area 51 that's so perfect so
basically the actual level with the
shooting and the fighting occurs kind of
underground starts off on this train you
gotta get this train started to go to a
location to plant a nuke to kill the
commandant so there's a whole process
but it was actually super challenging
and we do want to point out that an hour
build the build in our UK office our au
office and a couple people in our
session that don't work for GameSpot
that we talked to you all had balance
issues with this section it seems like
it's just a work in progress still so
you know we were getting like one-hit ko
die yeah thank you ler guys not even
like Meck Meck dude soz it was clearly
like not finished and that was a
challenge in and of itself but there is
actually is difficulty there that's not
from the imbalancing issues it was you
know you're kind of scrounging for
weapons there's a lot of enemies that
wants you to deal with you can kind of
be stealthy you can take multiple routes
through this train right to the front
and so there's a lot going on it was
actually really cool yeah if you claim
your border it's it's sort of the
typical like gameplay formula you expect
break crates to find health and ammo you
know you can try and stealth your way
through they have the officers who you
need to kill in order to so that they
can't keep resetting more guards stuff
like that instead of a knife now you get
em a hatchet and you can you can still
throw it though so you can do like sick
hatchet throws which is really fun
that's a new thing but they're also a
a little bit about dual-wielding you
played on mouse keyboard I played on
with an Xbox controller
I found dual-wielding to be extremely
cumbersome because with the controller
you have like two wheels you have to
manage uhm well so we should say that
your living was in the new order but in
race one you can do wield separate
weapons right that's the new thing sorry
yeah the so but the hard thing is here
in the middle of a firefight switching
weapons or if you run an ammo it's just
it doesn't the pace doesn't suit a
controller for me which is how I played
new orders I was a little disappointed
by that right it's um I think when
you're playing on controller it seems
like you might have to set that up
before you go into the firefight you
need firefight if you're trying to like
okay I want to put a shotgun on my left
and I want this hand I have a pistol
it's gonna be a bit messy and you're
probably gonna die another thing that
was a little yeah I think you just got
to get used to it is when you're when
you're doing if you your left gun runs
out of ammo it automatically just
switches that hand to another gun and in
the middle of a firefight you're not
really paying attention to that so I'm
just like dueling with the shotguns and
then all of a sudden I had like a
submachine gun in my other hand and it I
was like what was like why am I not like
shooting properly and like oh I suddenly
have this gun in my hand yeah and I was
a bit weird you have to adjust mentally
cuz that can be cool I mean that's the
new thing right and can be like okay if
I find a heavy I have this weapon ready
in my left hand and if I find an officer
I have this other you know less powerful
weapon you can save ammo that way but
it's just a lot to take on I do want to
move on though to the story because in
this second section that we got to play
you're in Roswell obviously and it's
just so cool the the world-building they
have here obviously Wolfenstein it's an
alternate history where the Nazis won so
a lot of things are going to be
different but they stick to
you know real life real-world
institution so you can see a useless and
III the you know fully-clothed KKK
members Walker broswell during this Nazi
victory parade
there's cool things like Abbey Road but
with very distinctly Nazi imagery it's
like an alternate version of a beer
right yeah that kind of stuff was in the
first game right there they were there
going forward with that a lot yeah it
feels like they're really just building
upon it it was rich and that's secret
like I think the first time you and I
played it because we got to play a
couple different times we walked around
for like 15 minutes just reading oh yeah
there's like a drunk guy in an alleyway
yelling about Nazis there's there's a
young couple being like ich liebe dich
yeah there's some people like wait in
line for a movie talking about like the
latest like weird alternate history Nazi
movie there's some great book that you
could like read the description of
that's talking about a like alternate
like dystopian future where the Allies
won oh yeah and it's like these freedom
fighters have to fight against like the
oppressive regime of gay people and Jews
yeah oh it's like this like struggle it
was yes it's a book roughly they do not
hold back they are going for her yeah
it's a book review of somebody
describing this like fantastic dystopian
novel where the Allies won there's also
like this wasn't in Roswell but you can
find you know notes and stuff all around
the world obviously there was one that
was like a newspaper like a letter to
the editor that was like thank you to
the Nazis for liberating us traveling
yeah I just appreciate all that I really
loved it's you know its environmental
storytelling in a way but I like the
storytelling that's
a little bit tuck behind you you can go
in guns blazing or you can kind of route
around and find those things and I
really liked how they were developing
that I do want to talk a little bit
about just actual like the plot
continuing straight from the order and
the rioters yeah so it's very much like
a direct direct continuation I think
they said like it takes place only like
a couple months after the end
yeah the at the very beginning in that
wheelchair section set tells BJ like
you've been in bed for five months I
think yeah bedridden a record valuation
yes the characters like set Ross and and
Anya like the triangle obviously you saw
max max has character he's back in it
like all these characters are back in
which having just replayed then you
order like a week before we actually saw
this I look forgotten how many like
characters were in that game so I feel
like if you have not played it if you've
not played the new order I mean
absolutely yeah absolutely gonna play
it's an amazing game but you might be a
bit lost in the story I don't know if
they'll have hopefully and they'll have
like a refresher maybe get people up to
speed but if you played it and kind of
like when it came out and kind of proud
I definitely recommend playing it by
anyone before playing it yeah it seems
like they're not necessarily as
interested in trying to like it's like a
fresh new story that like anyone can
jump into like I'm sure they want as
many people to play as possible but the
story is very much like this is for the
people that likes that previous game and
want more of that yeah absolutely and I
think mechanically is it similar so you
you know if you liked how that game
built to play it's the same rising deal
yeah another interesting though is that
they are continuing the alternate
branching story paths yes this game
they're not doing like you think about a
game like the dishonored to where that
first game had multiple story endings
and for two they just picked one of
these story endings
made that the canonical ending we're not
doing that for this one they're actually
like continuing letting you play through
both the Wyatt and the Ferguson time why
don't you explain how you know that oh
yeah because in in the two demos we
played the tooth levels there are
multiple cutscenes and you can see one
has Ferguson in it and you can see
another one has white right it's like we
weren't told that directly but we kind
of extrapolated right yeah but in like
the first one like they seemed to go
really all out with it where there's
lots of like separate cutscenes and
dialogue with those two characters so
it's not just more superficial like
they're they're really leaning into that
still which is great because that was
bad a lot of replay value to that first
game was being able to play those two
alternate like timelines yeah absolutely
so it seems like they're carrying in
that through but yeah overall we had a
lot of fun with it it was cool and you
know it's just it's very like you said
pulpy is such a great way to describe
Wolfenstein and I'm really excited to
jump back into that world if you want to
check it out we have more Wolfenstein
gameplay and cut scenes more on GameSpot
and YouTube so be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss any of those and if you
like this video give us a like you
really have this helps us out thank you
so much for watching